qu'on trouve que c'est normal au québec
d'avoir
entre guillements quémander lorsqu'on a
une menace directe sur sa personne que
d'avoir une escorte c'est ça c'est pas
normal il faut vraiment être naïf pour
croire qu'un pays comme le canada g 709
coûte plus cher friend à ce que faudra
maintenant pour dire qu'on aura pas une
protection pour des gens aussi important
que les dix premières manifs du canada
mais c'est qu'au québec les élus nous on
n'a même pas ce qu'on appelle le bouton
panique qui devrait être déployée
prochainement le mot je demandé
des menaces des agressions menaces
d'agressions c'est une nouvelle réalité
pour la classe politique et je poursuis
avec marie ève carignan professeur à
l'université de sherbrooke et directrice
du pôle média de la chaire unesco en
prévention de la radicalisation et de
l'extrémisme violent bon sens alain
carignon
madame dessous écoutez on a eu
certainement beaucoup d'émotion entendre
le point de presse de madame rice qui
c'est le message laissé par son
agresseur entre sur l'homme qui la
menace elle était terrifiant comment
expliquer ces incidents puisque une
augmentation selon vous
mais on a vraiment beaucoup d'incidents
là depuis quelques jours quelques
semaines est bon c'est vrai que le fait
d'en parler après d'augmenter aussi le
signalement ce qu'on a eu du coup de
deux candidats sortir et dénoncé les
propos violents qui leur étaient
adressées sur les réseaux sociaux puis
demandé à ce qu'on va faire la
modération des commentaires mais en
effet ce qu'on a vu au fédéral qu'on a
vu chez des candidats ce qu on a même vu
chez des bénévoles comme par exemple
bénévoles qui est cédée des pancartes
électorales il ya quelques jours et qui
s'est fait aussi à dire et c est très
inquiétant c'est un signe qu'en ce
moment au bord vraiment une espèce de
ras-le-bol de certaines personnes par
rapport aux mesures sanitaires une
mécompréhension aussi du rôle du
gouvernement dans la gestion de cette
crise là qui a peut être augmentée le
une certaine frustration envers le
politique et pour certaines personnes
mais cette frustration le surtout quand
on se radicalisent dans certaines idées
parce que prenez l'exemple de mme adam
freeland c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui
adhérer la différente peu de
considération liste est donc souvent ces
gens là qui adhère la déside un peu plus
extrêmes mais nos recherches le montre
c'est des gens qui considèrent aussi que
c'est plus légitime disons que la
moyenne la population de pouvoir le
recourir à la violence pour faire
entendre leurs propos ou revendiquer
leurs idées politiques
avez vous constaté dans vos recherches
une augmentation du passage à l'acte
on a constaté au cours de la pandémie
vraiment le plus documenté plusieurs
dizaines de cas où on a notamment arrêté
des gens qui s'étaient armés qui a
l'ambition de se faire justice eux-mêmes
qui avait tenu des propos haineux sur
les réseaux sociaux qui sont pas
toujours conscients que ses propos
peuvent avoir des conséquences le direct
dans leur vie de tous les jours puis qui
peuvent mener à des arrestations dont
puis on a vu une augmentation du passage
à l'acte et c'est vraiment inquiétant
parce que ce qu'on entendait notamment
dans le propos de madame rice qui sait
que ça a un impact sur la démocratie si
les politiciens peuvent plus des bars
doivent s'empêcher d'aller dans
différents événements mais ce qui risque
d'arriver c'est un impact sur le débat
démocratique
le libre débat qui connaissent pas que
sur la vie politique de tous les
citoyens donc il faut vraiment ramener
une réflexion à long terme sur
l'importance du débat puis mieux faire
comprendre le fonctionnement
démocratique ou une forme d'ignorance de
manque d'éducation c'était de se faire
justice soi même
mais c'est certain que certaines
personnes qui comprennent pas
nécessairement le fonctionnement
politique démocratique on le vit par
exemple avec des jantes aua par exemple
qui voulait remplacer des élus par des
citoyens et qui parfois comprennent pas
nécessairement le mode de fonctionnement
politique il ya un lien dans nos données
on le voit là les gens qui adhèrent
davantage par exemple à des idées
conspirationnistes ou à des fosses
d'information belle vote souvent - qui
votent en particulier pour certains
partis qui sont souvent plus à droite
sur l'échiquier politique mais oui je
pense qu'à long terme non seulement pour
ceux qui adhèrent à la désinformation
mes courses ou qui ont été ébranlés par
la crise pandémique est une réflexion à
faire c'est comment on peut rétablir la
confiance dans le débord pu mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement
démocratique et je sais pas comment on
répond à certains de ses frustrations à
cette colère qui veulent à 100 au fond
il ya je pense à court terme il faut
vraiment passer à l'action pour protéger
les élus leur permettent de jouer leur
rôle de pouvoir débarque donc il va
falloir gamin à la fois leur donner
peut-être des formations sur comment
réagir comme en avant certains
comportements qui vont assurer leur
sécurité
renforcée aussi peut-être le notamment
au niveau fédéral au roi du politiste
ont vraiment feu accompagnés en termes
de sécurité je pense qu'on a une
réflexion en force que la ford n y
démontre qu'une certaine escalade de
violence on le voit avec aussi les
professionnels de l'information même
avoir des chercheurs comme dont je suis
alors faut protéger mais à long terme
mais c'est une réflexion plus large sur
comment on peut prévenir ce genre de
situation d'un dialogue dans le débat
social dans les poutres de caisse qui
ont mené cette frustration là pour être
mieux gérer les communications
gouvernementales à l'avenir puis krivine
et non que ces gars-là delà il ya un
appel aussi à assurer des mesures de
sécurité notamment à ottawa on se rend
compte qu'ils avaient pas assez de
mesures de sécurité au québec et en
heure pour les ministres on verra pour
les députés entre reçu également pour
madame marie ce qui met de madame rice
qui ont révélé que la couronne
s'opposait à la remise en liberté de cet
individu qui s'est fait menaçant et
violent dans ses propos et le ou la juge
je ne connais pas l'identité de deux
juges tout la juge mais le remis en
liberté avec des conditions puis une des
conditions c'est d'aller voir son
médecin traitant pour une évaluation
psychiatrique alors non seulement sur
quelle planète peut-être et se jugent ou
sept juges ont d'abord s'assurer qu'un
médecin traitant puisque le être temps
peut faire une évaluation rapidement de
la santé mentale pendant ce temps long
exposé madame b ce qui est ce que ça
vous inquiète ce genre de décision là
mais c'est certain que je connais pas
exactement ce qui a motivé le jeu
l'ensemble du dossier pour prendre sa
décision
mais en tout cas j'espère qu'on renforce
la sécurité d'un manteau de madame rice
qui est oui en campagne électorale c'est
d'autant plus inquiétant parce que c'est
aussi un moment crucial pour les
candidats pour faire entendre leurs
idées donc il faut qu'ils soient privés
de ce moment là vraiment pour débattre
plus pouvoir aller le devant de la scène
donc c'est sûr que c'est un moment
charnière où on veut pour empêcher débat
démocratique
on sent très bien l'inquiétude de madame
risquez de vous remercie beaucoup marié
de carignan d'abord partager votre
expertise avec tout ce soir tant voir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit